I am announcing the first tranche of sanctions.
These sanctions are a major step and we hold further sanctions
at readiness to be deployed.
The U.
S.
And its allies coordinated a first round of sanctions against Russia over its troop deployment to
breakaway regions of Ukraine.
They're hoping the financial pressure that the sanctions create in Russia will
discourage Moscow from going any further into
eastern Ukraine or we're using his force to take over the country
entirely.
The sanctions are expected to have limited impact on Russia's economy,
but western governments say they send a strong signal.
The US blacklisted two major banks and ban the trade of any new sovereign debt.
While some allies said they would sanction individuals connected to the breakaway regions and
impose travel bans.
The political message that that sends to Moscow is hey,
you're going to be politically isolated from from the global economy where all of these
actions will also affect the price or the exchange rate of the
ruble.
But one penalty is sparking concerns for international energy markets.
Germany's decision to put the Nord Stream two pipeline on hold.
An $11 billion Europe.
And these are father associates
escalates
andre diplomatic mission and strangled the US had long called for the pipelines opening to be
halted and Germany froze the project,
even though it's the biggest buyer of Russian gas in the world.
The European Union also relies on Russia with about 40% of natural gas supplies coming from
there,
Cutting off future natural gas imports through the North North Stream two
project that's already pushed the natural gas prices up five times what they were last
winter.
That's a big cost that Europe didn't want to take.
But it also shows how serious europe believes the threat
of Russia's invasion into eastern Ukraine is Russia's foreign ministry called the
actions illegitimate and an effort by the West to restrain the country's development.
As Russia contemplates his next move,
we have our next move prepared as well.
President Biden said,
there will be steeper penalties if Russia continues its aggression and launches a full scale invasion
beyond the breakaway regions.
They are a signal to warn Russia that they're serious about
delivering on their threats,
but offering Moscow an opportunity to
restrain their own efforts and that more measured approach,
say some analysts allow for a de escalation of potential de
escalation of the tensions,
uh,
an off ramp to
diplomacy